please welcome Jarvis Cocker
[Applause]
thanks has a weight ever been an issue
for you wait I mean I just looked at
some old pictures Harry well I'm getting
ready to play some concert soon so yes
weight is on my mind because and vain
just like everybody else
so yes can that can that kind of of
self-consciousness or as you call it
being vain can that get in the way of
creativity I think self-consciousness is
the enemy of creativity because I think
to be creative you have to kind of allow
ideas to flow and if you think too much
about it I think we're all familiar with
that you know the thing of overthinking
can really mess things up that's what
I've found anyway over the years yeah so
I'm always trying to find ways to forget
about myself yeah so how do you do that
what are the race partner up the drugs
though that actually goes the other way
in my experience such as it is which we
weren't going to well I can tell you
what I've been doing recently which is
I've been working on some new songs and
the way that I decided to do it was to
take them out and actually play them and
so finish the songs by playing them to
people and that was a good way of
getting over the self-consciousness
because you performed something and then
you can feel from people's reaction to
it what needs to be done you know what
would be the things should it be more
exciting at this part should it go quiet
here so the songs when you when you do
that today that's nice so when you
you're working
it's either on a song or a text or
whatever are you fueled by by conviction
or doubt I don't think you could become
have total conviction when you created
something because part of the reason to
create something is to find out what you
think about a certain thing what I'm
trying to do through writing songs or
anything is to find out try and find out
what I think about the world you know
cuz I I'm fascinated by the world and
and mainly fascinated by other people in
the world and what motivates them and
what they get up to and I'm very curious
about all that kind of thing you came
you came from a world of sex drugs and
drugs and rock and roll as they call it
not really Sheffield to Sheffield
[Applause]
it's got sexy drugs made while people
drink a lot and rock and roll wellhe
it's yeah it's yeah it's a lot of bands
of come from Sheffield even Joe Cocker
came from you did yes he apparently he
he babysat for me when I was a young
child I'm not related to him but he was
friends with my father but that's
something exclusive what what do you
find most difficult to write about I
mean do you fight it because you can
describe sexuality in a song hmm
do you find that difficult I know that
many authors find it difficult to write
about that I think it's a valid thing to
write about because basically none of us
would be here without some sex having
taken place so I mean I I've I have
written about it and mainly because I
guess that you know I took a lot of my
ideas about love and sex from songs that
I heard on the radio when I was a child
and so then when I reached adolescence
and actually
started wanting to have a girlfriend and
all this kind of thing I found that my
first experiences really didn't have
didn't seem at all like what I thought
sex was gonna be from hearing it in
songs you know I thought it was all
gonna be fantastic and only last three
minutes so I wanted to write about a
more human side of it because sex and
love that often are quite awkward things
to deal with because you're dealing with
emotions and and no one can tell you how
to do it properly it's really something
that you have to find out for yourself
you know and you are very vulnerable you
know it's a two people together in bed
that's the closest you're ever going to
be with someone there's no hiding behind
anything no it's in a way it's a very
awkward situation yes but also when
they'll start to think about it it has a
very yeah when you start to think about
it that's the problem you you mustn't
think of that you have to feel it you
know you have to the self-consciousness
is really problematic yeah I've avoided
writing about sex for ten books I've
just made it really easy for me they
turn out the light and you have to think
about the rest and what's the main thing
that's been stopping me is it's been
awkward it's been embarrassing and I
pictured my mother reading my books so
this was a big obstacle for me and it's
been way way out of my comfort zone but
that's also why it's been so much fun
yeah it's been really a challenging to
try to do it well because it is hard to
write about sex
well and yeah it's fun except for the
part that my mother now calls these two
books my sex books
Jarvis you you have this I wouldn't call
it a book I would call it a pamphlet or
something like that it's a very thin
book it's two speeches actually it's
called bad pop good pop good cop laptop
yeah tell me what is good
bad Bob yeah well this is a panther I
wrote I don't know if it's been the sink
or brexit having written I was asked to
well uh I'm a very much in favor or was
very much in favor of Britain stain and
part of of the because I spend quite a
lot of time in Paris my son is educated
in Paris so I have a feeling of both
places you know and so it was a quite
personal thing for me in the wake of the
referendum in the UK the big thing was
saying well this decision is the will of
the people that can mean a thing that
people saying that and what I was trying
to say was not really because if you
looked at the referendum resolve which
was like 52 percent to 48 percent that
would be the equivalent of a record
going into the top 40 at number 19 and
that's not that's not number one is it
that's not even in top 10 that's not
like a popular thing that's that's like
a kind of a failure really so I know
so the idea that then this result was
presented as the will of the people it
wasn't and and and how come it was well
they've all said yes to brexit yeah very
narrowly yeah with with some accusations
of child rigging chart ringing yes and
it led me on to thinking about you know
my belief is that the pop charts used to
be quite an interesting phenomenon
really they was a obviously it's a
commercial thing but also was quite
democratic and it was a kind of popular
democracy because people would buy
record and really be involved in whether
that record got to the top he bought the
record and it was kind of like giving a
vote yeah and and sometimes I'm sure it
probably happened in Sweden as well but
it certainly in the UK sometimes you
would get very strange records getting
to the top of the chart the one that I
always remember is this record Oh
Superman by Laurie Anderson do you know
that song no the thing is that that song
I think got to number two so this is
what you call good pop I would call that
good pop yeah so bad pop is bad pop is
more recent years which is populism
rather than popularity which is playing
to the to the baser instincts of we
always commenting on we all yeah we all
that base instincts no way but but
playing to that and and really bribing
people when you go home to Sheffield
yeah a chef voted for brexit a bit yeah
my mother voted for Greg said yeah just
imagine that good Christmas was
difficult this year
it was yeah Christmas is very different
now so we had to say nobody talks about
politics at the Christmas table and if
it comes up I'm going to make a really
high-pitched sound which I did twice but
yeah because he's just and that's it you
know that's the tragedy of what it's
done to the to the country you know I
think that's the thing that there have
always been differences of opinion
obviously I need any you know free
society not everybody's going to believe
the same thing but but basically
everybody kind of would try and put
those things aside and try and get on
with things perhaps it won't get better
perhaps it will get worse who knows the
only issues between you and your mother
in the end of the day though there are
many issues thank you so much Jarvis
Cocker thank you very much hope you
enjoyed the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe
you